Lady pépette sortière disco texte de
Christine nmann villemain illustration
de Stéphane segas caléïdoscope
c'est l'histoire d'une sorcière méchante
très très méchante et affreuse vraiment
affreuse évidemment une seule chose
l'intéresse manger des
enfants mais comme elle est moche
terriblement moche les enfants se sauve
dès qu'il la voit et elle n'en attrape
jamais elle a bien essayé d'en piéger
deux en les attirant dans sa maison en
pain d'épic mais ce n'était pas une très
bonne idée les deux garnements l'ont
enfermé dans le four et lui ont volé ses
économies
elle décide alors de se rendre au
Congrès des sorcières qui est l'endroit
rêvé pour connaître les dernières
nouveautés en matière de piège à enfant
que deviens-tu lui demande la fé carabos
ça marche les affaires oh là là dur dur
ça fait une éternité que je n'ai pas
attrapé d'enfant ah les temps changent
interviennent la vieille pustula les
bonbons sont dépassés les enfants
d'aujourd'hui veulent des paillettes du
spectacle pour les attirer il leur faut
de l'exceptionnel du sensationnel du
showbusiness du grandiose bref il faut
les épatterer les sidérer les
scotchers la sorcière prend des notes et
s'en retourne chez elle avec un plan
d'enfer grandtin relooking grand 2 cours
de chant grand 3 cours de danse à
l'institut de beauté l'esthéticienne se
désole oh là là il y a du travail ma
petite dame depuis combien de temps
n'avez-vous pasit fait de masque
hydratant votre peau est toute sèche et
ses grands poils sur le menton toute la
semaine la sorcière se fait patouiller
chouchouter pomponné c'est dur mais à la
fin le résultat lui plaît au
conservatoire de la chanson la
professeur en a les oreilles écanchées
ou ouill ou il y a du boulot reprenez au
clair de la lune pour voir oh oh oh oh
oh non arrêtez toute la semaine notre
sorcière fait des mamemi MoMu des doré
mi façoles c'est dur mais à la fin le
résultat lui plaît à l'école de danse la
professeure en reste les bras
ballants et ben c'est pas gagné tournez
un peu pour voir les bras comme ça bon
on repart à zéro savez-vous où sont vos
pieds toute la semaine la sorcière fait
du hip hop des claquette du flamenco et
des petits sauts et arrêtez les
cacahuètes ordonne la danseuse vous avez
de trop trop grossse fesse la sorcière
est épuisée mais à la fin le résultat
lui plaît de retour chez elle la
sorcière se dit qu'il lui faut un nom de
scène quelque chose qui sonne bien
facile à retenir Suzy Dolly Laurine
zazette Lady Lady pépette oui ça c'est
un nom toute contente de sa trouvaille
elle s'enferme dans son salon et met au
point un numéro qu'elle répète sans
relâche jusqu'à ce qu'il soit parfait
puis elle s'inscrit à une émission de
télévision le grand jour arrive lorsque
vient son tour de monter sur la scène
elle se présente bonsoir cher public je
m'appelle Lady pépette et je suis
danseuse chanteuse ma chanson danser
s'intitule viens dans ma maison tu
verras mon chaudron attention ça va
décoiffer alors elle se lance sur la
piste ça swing ça rock ça claque elle
chauffe la salle vraiment quel style
qu'elle voix le succès est immédiat tout
le monde veut l'imiter les filles se
coiffent comme elle les garçons sifflent
sa chanson on lui demande des
autographes des photos dédicacé des
interviews un matin on sonne à sa porte
une petite fille toute dodu et potelé
pas comme cette grande andouille de
Gretel une vraie maigr chonne celle-là
oh Lady je t'adore je suis depuis le
début de ta carrière youpi se dit la
sorcière mon plan a marché j'ai réussi
elle jubile enfin elle a réussi à tirer
un enfant je connais toutes les figures
par cœur continue la fillette regarde un
pas en avant demi-tour l s'approche
doucement elle se lèche déjà les babines
claque des mains poursuit la gamine les
doigts crochus aux ongles vernis se
tendent vers la mignonne
HM petit mouvement du bassin pirouette à
gauche mais non à droite la pirhouette
s'entant conseiller Lady vous êtes sûr
c'est quand même moi qui l'ai inventé
cette chorégraphie et après demande la
petite fille après petit pas tourne la
tête une de claque des doigts non pas
comme ça comme ça ah oui j'ai compris
tiens se dit Lady et si j'en faisais une
danseuse elle pourrait être derrière moi
ça ferait pas mal dans mon spectacle bon
tiens oui d'accord bonne idée mais le
prochain enfant je le mange le lendemain
on sonne à la porte un petit garçon sont
tout mignon et très appétissant pas
comme cette grande asperge d'un sel qui
sentait le chou Lady Lady s'éce l'enfant
hystérique prends-moi dans ton Chud
regarde je danse hyper bien ah non se
dit la tortière celui-là je le boulotte
mais le gamin s'est déjà lancé dans une
démonstration
ahurissante après tout il serait pas mal
dans mon numéro se dit Lady bon mais le
prochain jure et cracher je le
mange le lendemain D donong une classe
de CE1 toute entière envahi le perron
quel festin se réjouit Lady je vais même
pouvoir en surgeler oh Lady On adore ce
que tu fais dit le délégué de classe on
est venu pour apprendre les pasain Lady
réfléchit quelques instants et une idée
lumineuse surgit dans son esprit et si
je montais une comédie musicale elle
s'intitulerait Lady pépettes et les
pépites the show il y aurait des effets
spéciaux des danseurs sur sort géant des
figures renvolant Lady pépette rêv la
troupe irait en tourner à Las Vegas puis
dans le monde entier il y aurait des
vêtements Lady pépette des sacs Lady
pépette oui c'est ça je suis génial
réflexion faite ce n'est pas tellement
intéressant de croquer les enfants c'est
gras et sucré et je n'ai pas intérêt à
prendre du poids si je veux faire du
cinéma